well we're talking about the idea of
proof it was all about how to take logic
and apply it to a situation how do you
try and develop new knowledge based on
things you already know and advance your
understanding of a topic or an idea
right now the whole idea that we were
trying to get across in this course is
there's more ways to prove things than
just the ways that you've experienced
and pretty much all the proofs you've
done have really been in geometry you
know you prove that a triangle is
isosceles or you prove that two lines
are parallel so that's been the call
style of proofs that you could doing but
last week we looked at proof by
contradiction which is a whole different
way of doing things very backwards you
assume something doesn't isn't you know
true and that you prove that it is
mathematical induction is very similar
now it's really important you probably
hear me say by induction and I will sort
of just as a informal conversational
colloquial way but it's actually really
important that you call this
mathematical induction because the word
induction means a lot of things that are
very different to different groups of
people I'll give you an example some of
you at home when you're when you're
watching like if you or your parents or
anyone else in your family is cooking
right on your cooktop there's lots of
different kinds of cook tops right for
example there's gas in their home yes
okay good so you've got a fire coming
out of your stovetop I do not have gas
unfortunately so therefore I've got an
electric cooktop and that electric
cooktop as long as your arm your what's
it called your gas cooktops with a fire
they weren't by conduction right this is
a scientific word
what does conduction we still do yeah
okay something conducts it you've got
something hot and something else hot and
just by virtue of their being
next to each other there's a transfer of
energy and therefore heat right so
that's conduction but you also have
induction cooktops and they don't work
by you know just being hot and just be
quiet in fact you can turn an inductor
cooktop stove top on you can turn on to
maximum and then you can touch it with
your hand because it does it actually
feel hot it works plane magnetism and it
actually induces an electric current
that produces heat in your department
pressive right so that's what induction
means in in physics induction also has a
beating when we talk about just argument
so this is actually more relevant to us
for instance suppose you go you go
traveling right and you already another
country you're eating food and you go to
a restaurant and you eat the food there
and it makes you really really unwell
you feel really sick you're like well
okay now was it good so the next day you
go to a different restaurant on the same
street and you eat the food and it makes
you feel sick as well you're like this
is not very good what kind of holiday is
is so you're like okay third time lucky
you go to a third restaurant side street
and you feel sick again okay three
different restaurants three different
days but you you get ill or each one of
them okay now what we would do is you
would say what are you going to go to
that same street and it's a place for
the fourth day probably not and what
you're doing is you're in play you're
applying inductive logic the idea simply
is and this is important to write down
because it's a common leak you are
generalizing from a small data set this
is a very technical way of saying it but
when I explain what this means in terms
that I just gave you an analogy you'll
want to say it small data set means you
haven't seen every single restaurant on
this street you haven't seen every
single restaurant in this country it's a
small data set you haven't tested
everything but it's a large enough data
set then you could say well I think
there's a pattern here I think generally
speaking maybe eating on this street is
a bad idea or individual foods just
doesn't agree with me so we make a sort
of logical leap boys awesome based on
this small data set okay now that's a
medical induction is like this but it's
up it's better because when you
generalize you're a small data set and
you could be wrong right do you agree
like the fourth restaurant actually
might have been fired
you don't actually know until you
actually have a go or maybe in the fifth
or the sixth or conceivably even 92 I
restaurants could be bad and then 101 is
good so this always has a bit of sort of
wiggle room is blurry is not quite true
right that's the way life is
but mathematical deduction is a bit
different mathematical abduction
actually has at its core the same kind
of deductive logic deductive not
inductive that you've been using all
along and I'm going to show you I'm
going to give you the session how this
works here's my illustration I'm going
to need some help
I'm going to give you guys um actually I
want you to pick a number and get your
calculator out because some of you might
pick big numbers I want you to pick a
number between one and a hundred right
pick a number between one and 100 and
with your chosen number I want you to
put it into this expression here where
your chosen number will be n so maybe
you choose five or 18 or 53 I actually
don't know numbers get pretty big pretty
fast when you put it stuff up in powers
so I don't know if you choose another to
live your calculator just spit it back
out at you and say I can't handle this
but I'd like you to have a go pick it
over and once you've got a number I'd
like you to tell me what it is and we'll
write all the boards for the shot okay
fix it
okay who's got some numbers for me first
I want to hear you what's that over you
thought up and then secondly I want to
hear what your calculator display tells
you can someone give you start yeah go
here click yep there's very much ok so
give me the other side you got one yep
I'm still writing down my number
yep and step 33 okay excellent
can I get another couple that'd be good
too else inserting yeah yeah go ahead
630 good and let's go for one more every
do you have another yep 207 was that
right okay fantastic
now what I want you to have a look at
with all these numbers because uh we're
pretty good at working out with numbers
and divisible by three we have a test
for this it's really simple how do you
find out if a number is divisible by
three you yeah okay you're doing some
addi can you be a little more specific
what are we adding up the the digits yes
so we can quickly test this right we're
going to go very quickly and I'm going
to need your help with um with this
number here 423 out of the digits you
get of course nine that checks out what
about I'll come down here this one you
get you get nine again so that looks
good 50 2113 or so you get 12 issue and
I have no idea I will try to stall her
summer work this out one already
well hold on we want to add up the
digits right just the digits yeah what
is it
2 plus 6 plus 5 plus 0 got it poor you
have calculators I have the exact truth
forty-two which again you can do again
which is the nice thing in case you
can't remember that 42 is divisional I
agree great this works okay so this all
looks fantastic so far what we've done
is we've experimented right this is what
a scientist does a scientist try things
out see if there's a pattern it's like
well this has happened many many times I
can be reasonably confident okay so if
all we were doing was just looking at
this and say it's pretty good there
we'll be doing just inductive logic but
what we're going to do now is
mathematical induction which is more
than just throwing stuff at the wall and
seeing what sticks it's actually being a
little more rigorous and it's got three
steps that I'm going to illustrate for
you and I want you to work out how is it
that this these three steps together
prove that if not just probably true but
actually it's always true okay so I'm
going to show you three steps and I want
you to have the gears turning your head
as to why this works okay the three
steps could be neatly for the word
pap-pap okay so t-stance a test now when
you test we've been testing we've been
testing we've been testing somewhat
random values when we test over here for
mathematical induction not just like
regular reduction you have to test a
specific value namely the first one have
a look n can't be just any number for
example n can't be 1/2 and can't be
negative 3 n has to be a certain kind of
knowledge do you remember what this some
weird set of symbols and notation means
what's that about positive integers very
good I get the positive for the plus and
that is our symbol for integers so
therefore the first number that
satisfies this rule the first one has to
be one so that has to be the number that
I test ok again I want you to have a
think as I go through this why once they
test the first one and it doesn't it's
not enough to test any random number it
has to be this one so we could all do
this together let's have a look at this
thing if I test for N equals 1 I'm going
to get 7 to power
- 4 ^ 3 do you agree so that's 7
takeaway 64 that's negative 57 I think
which is divisible by 3 it's a bit weird
this question you know divisibility we
usually only think about in terms of
positive numbers but this checks out 57
itself is divisible by 3 so I'm happy
with that okay so therefore I now know
that this statement is true for the
first possible value okay